Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sagt mal habt ihr in Österreich eigentlich auch König.
Für Österreich, das wäre die Krönung.
Musik Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 459 vom 8.
Mai, immer noch 2023, genau und ihr habt es schon gehört, Thomas ist da, hallo Thomas.
Hallo Tim.
Denn Linus ist noch außer Puste
von der letzten Sendung und muss mal kurz aussetzen, so ist das halt.
Ja, aber wir wollten dich ja sowieso mal wieder zurück in der Sendung begrüßen
und insofern passt das ja ganz gut.
Ja, freut mich hier zu sein. Wir haben einen fetten Themen Sack mitgebracht.
Ja, aber einen König habt ihr nicht.
Nein, aber wie geht es dir so als halber Brite jetzt mit dieser Krönung?
Hat das irgendwas mit dir gemacht? Du hast es dir so sicher angeschaut, oder?
Ich habe es mir natürlich nicht angeschaut.
Bist du dem entkommen? Also ich hatte das, das Internet war voll damit.
Ich bin dem wirklich weitgehend, ich habe das eigentlich im Wesentlichen nicht
wirklich zur Kenntnis genommen. Also mich interessiert das auch wirklich gar nicht.
Also es ist einfach für mich überhaupt gar kein Thema, was mich auch nur ansatzweise
in irgendeiner Form emotional tangiert. Das ist belanglos.
Ich habe das ja eh schon mal gesagt. Ich habe eine gewisse Faszination mit mir
fremden, bösartigen Organisationen wie Katholische Kirche, FIFA und Adelshäuser gehören dazu.
Ich habe mir das natürlich angesehen und in Österreich haben wir ja irgendwie,
wir waren ja nur mal etwas so als Land, als wir noch eine Monarchie hatten.
Da waren wir groß und einflussreich.
Es gibt eine gewisse Faszination in Österreich mit Monarchie,
auch wenn das ja irgendwie nach dem ersten Weltkrieg verboten ist bei uns.
Adelstitel von und zu gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Aber ich habe mir das angeschaut und es war faszinierend wie inhaltsleer es
ist und wie schlecht die Performance war.
Ich meine, dieser Typ hat sich sein gesamtes Leben auf diesen Moment vorbereitet
und das wirkte jetzt nicht so, als hätte das auch für ihn in dem Moment jetzt
irgendwas Erhebendes gehabt.
Und ich meine, sowas soll ja irgendwie verzaubern und vielleicht sogar eine
Verbindung zu Gott herstellen.
Dadurch wird es ja legitimiert, aber davon habe ich gar nichts mitbekommen oder gespürt.
Ja so ein bisschen unbeteiligt finde ich wirkt der generell und ist aber ich
mache mir wirklich also überhaupt gar keine Gedanken darüber und mich tangiert
das auch jetzt so mit meiner Reststaatsbürgerschaft eigentlich wenig.
Also ich meine ich habe natürlich mental irgendwie mit Britannien seit diesem
Brexit sowieso abgeschlossen so und warte jetzt sozusagen auf den Tag wo mich
das Land wieder beeindruckt.
Und das wird noch eine Weile dauern, glaube ich.
Und diese ganze Monarchie und Königsnummer ist halt so, ich weiß nicht,
was man davon überhaupt noch halten soll.
Also einerseits finde ich es belanglos, auf der anderen Seite finde ich es halt
auch so ein bisschen erschreckend, wie groß immer das Interesse daran ist,
weil es ist ja völlig uninteressant.
Also ich meine da passiert ja auch nichts. Die leben da irgendwie ihr Leben,
sind irgendwie öffentlich und alle quatschen darüber und interessieren sich
irgendwie dafür und es nimmt einfach so viel Raum ein, anstatt dass die Leute
sich über irgendwas interessantes unterhalten.
Aber ich meine, die Hoffnung haben wir glaube ich schon lange aufgegeben,
dass sich das in irgendeiner Form bessert.
So sind die Gesellschaften nun mal. Und warum jetzt ausgerechnet von Großbritannien
nochmal so ein besonderer Mythos ausgeht, das erschließt sich halt mir auch nur noch begrenzt.
Weil mal ehrlich, was hat die Queen jemals für uns getan? Also es ist sozusagen
nichts, die tun ja nichts.
Na Integrationsfigur, also schon irgendwie dieses das Land zusammenhalten,
ein Wir-Gefühl auslösen, ich glaube das hat die Queen durchaus noch.
Ja das hat ja super funktioniert beim Brexit.
Angeblich war doch Charles gegen den Brexit und die Queen dafür.
Hat man nur Mord und irgendwie.
Das würde ich so nicht bestätigen wollen, also ich weiß ja nicht, gut Gerüchte kannst du.
Hat Buckingham Palace auch gesagt.
Es ist halt, das Ding ist, sie äußern sich halt gar nicht dazu.
Das ist die einzige Äußerung, die es in irgendeiner Form zum Thema Brexit von
der Queen gab und auch das ist jetzt natürlich wirklich Kaffeesatz, Leserei, hoch zwei,
dass sie irgendwie nach diesem Votum in so einem blau-gelben Kostüm aufgetreten
ist und irgendwie irgendeinen Hut aufgehabt hat,
der so ähnlich gearbeitet war, dass man sagen könnte, das sind vielleicht so
die Sterne der EU-Flagge, weißt du, sowas.
Das ist sozusagen das einzige, was ich wahrgenommen habe, wo es mal so halbwegs
konkret wurde und ansonsten.
Hat es ja halt irgendwie nichts gemacht, dann hat es ja halt mal einmal eine Rede gehalten,
als irgendwie Corona war und alle durchgedreht sind in dem Land und das.
War aber halt auch nur so wischi waschi.
Ist natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen obszessiv, dass er dann auch wirklich
in jeder Fernsehsendung darüber reden muss, weil es natürlich dann auch wieder
so Eventgedöns ist und oh ja und hier und die Reuels und voll der Konflikt.
Wo ich halt sage so, ja okay gut, ich hab dem jetzt mal eine Viertelstunde mal zugehört,
was der eigentlich so, ich wollte einfach nur mal so wissen,
was der so moniert und vor allem wollte ich mal so reden hören und gucken,
ob ich der Meinung bin, dass er, also ob der alle Tassen im Schrank hat, so ja.
Und er entsinnt mich noch, als Harry so ein dummer Junge war,
hat er es ja auch mal so gebracht, auf irgendeiner Party ist er dann irgendwie in so einem...
Weiß nicht mehr ganz genau was es war, ne SS Uniform oder so,
irgendeine Nazi Klamotte hatte, das war halt so ein Skandalchen,
das rauschte mal so an mir vorbei, da dachte ich mir so,
na ok, es ist Boyd Brett irgendwie, was weiß ich, das ist halt so ein Mitglied
dieser Blasen Community Royals,
was kann man da schon groß von erwarten, aber wenn die Leute dann erwachsen
werden, dann wird es ja dann schon mal interessant zu sehen,
ob die halt in irgendeiner Form was machen, außer nur zum Pferdrennen zu gehen und Polo zu spielen.
Das stört mich eigentlich eher. Und ich verfolge schon seit längerem,
so bin ich da überhaupt draufgekommen.
Also ich hab vor ein paar Jahren, das ist jetzt auch schon eine Weile her,
Und dann habe ich halt so einen Film
gehabt, wo ich mir so auf YouTube so Atheisten-Kanäle angeschaut habe.
Sagt dir das was? Es gibt so eine Community von so Atheisten.
Also Richard Dawkins mäßig.
Dawkins ja genau, aber nochmal eine andere Nummer und zwar meistens handelt
es sich da einfach um sehr intelligente Menschen,
die in irgendeiner Form in so krass super religiösen Familien,
also in der Regel in den USA, aufgewachsen sind, wo so alle einen Schaden haben.
Und die dann aber irgendwann gecheckt haben, wie der Hase läuft und bei denen
ist das dann so komplett umgekippt und die sind dann halt in so einer vollen
Missionarsnummer unterwegs, dass sie halt irgendwie jetzt alle aufklären.
Und das ist eigentlich sehr interessant, weil die machen dann so Call-In-Shows und so.
Also gibt da so ein paar Größen, führt mir gerade der Name nicht ein,
kommt mir vielleicht gleich nochmal.
Wir machen so Call-In-Shows so nach dem Motto so ja okay ruft mich mal an irgendwie
und sagt mir mal warum ich Anlass haben sollte an so etwas wie einen Gott zu glauben.
Auf der einen Seite ist so sagen wir mal die Qualität der Argumentationen die
die Anrufer liefern in der Regel sehr überschaubar,
manchmal ist was ganz interessantes dabei, Aber was wirklich mich wirklich wirklich
wirklich beeindruckt hat ist, dass die mit einer krassen nerdhaftigen Logik argumentieren.
Ja also die nehmen wirklich diese ganzen Argumente fast schon mathematisch auseinander
und weisen dann sozusagen diesen Leuten auch so ihre Fehlschlüsse in ihrer Argumentation nach.
Das fand ich wirklich beeindruckend. Ein paar Leuten folge ich noch so ein bisschen
und die sind dann halt auch in diese Anti-Royals,
bei denen die jetzt sozusagen aus Großbritannien dann kommen und die waren dann
halt in so Debattenshows im Fernsehen,
wo dann halt so diese Moderatoren so völlig, also die haben diese Royal Skeptics
behandelt wie, wie soll man das vergleichen?
Aussätzige hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, ne also so Wahnsinnige,
wie könnt ihr nur das anzweifeln, von so einem Podest aus und dann auch so mit
so Argumentationen wie,
ja die Royals, die bezahlen, also die Kosten ist ja so ein Kritikpunkt,
ja das bezahlt sich ja alles von alleine, weil Tourismus und das fand ich dann
wirklich schon eine steile These.
Viel Tourismus in Österreich, in diesen ganzen Schlössern, und wir haben aber
schon lange keine Kaiser und keine König mehr.
Und ich meine, dazu muss man vielleicht schon noch etwas sagen,
jetzt bei dieser Krönung, die uns erstaunlich lange beschäftigt.
Es hat da natürlich auch massive Festnahmen gegeben und die haben extra nochmal
die Gesetze verschärft davor.
Und auch der hauptsächliche Vertreter der republikanischen Bewegung dort,
die Monarchie abzuschaffen, wurde verhaftet. Und die schönste Blüte war,
wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab, dass sie sogar Megafone verboten haben oder
Megafone der Grund für Festnahmen waren.
Und jetzt kommt's, die könnten ja die Pferde erschrecken.
Die können einfach mit Kritik überhaupt nicht umgehen und das erschüttert die
so in dem Manifesto und dann schaut man sich an so okay Leute worum geht es euch eigentlich um?
Ihr habt so eine Familie, die irgendwie euer halbes Land gehört und sozusagen
so Oberhaupt dieser ganzen Oberklasse ist,
die einfach den Großteil des Besitzes dieses Landes unter sich aufteilt und
für den Rest bleiben so ein paar Brotgruben über und sowas feiert ihr?
Also das finde ich also wirklich sowas von absurd und die können echt alle mal gehen.
Da ist nichts dabei. Vor allem das ist auch so eine sogenannte Elite,
die überhaupt keine Denker produziert. Hast du mal von irgend so einem Royal
gehört, der mal was kluges gesagt hat?
So irgendeine Debatte, irgendwann irgendwas, irgendein König hat so einen Graf von Hass nicht gesehen,
auch in Deutschland ist das ja irgendwie diese ganzen Von und Zus,
die wir ja noch haben, die geben ja auch alle nur Unsinn von sich und pinkeln
an irgendwelchen Wohnschaftsgebäuden und erzeugen Eklats,
das sind einfach Spoilt Brats, Einfach völlig mit sich selbst aufgefüllte Leute,
die einfach denken, sie wären was Besseres, obwohl alles was sie haben,
ist die Kohle von ihren Eltern.
Und das, das macht mich einfach...
Also fassungslos, wie man das auch noch toll finden kann und dann den ganzen
Tag das im Fernsehen live sendet,
also die Todeszeremonie von Diana, das war ja damals schon irgendwie extrem
so, das konnte ich irgendwie noch so ein bisschen nachvollziehen,
weil das war ja dann auch so ein Live-Drama, aber sorry, aber das geht gar nicht.
Ich glaube, du brauchst eine UKW-Folge, Tim, um das alles noch ordentlich zu
verarbeiten. Ich würde mich drüber freuen.
Also, man… Noch ein Tipp.
Das Buch von Harry Spare, das habe ich gelesen, das ist sogar ganz gut geworden,
um mal irgendwie so ein bisschen dahinter zu blicken, wie er auf diese Familie schaut.
Und es gibt auch eine Saufpark-Folge, die genau dieses, ach,
sie wollen jetzt in Ruhe gelassen werden und aus dem öffentlichen Licht und
gleichzeitig geben sie die ganze Zeit nur Interviews, Hat Saufpark wie es immer
dort passiert sehr gut überspitzt auf den Punkt gebracht.
Mal schauen ob wir das verlinken können.
Also du meinst jetzt das Buch von dem Prinz Harry oder was?
Genau, Spare.
Hast du das gelesen?
Ja. Wirklich? Ja, Audiobook, also das was man nebenher als Kuriosum sich mal zu Gemüte führt.
Da bist du schon weiter als ich.
Soll ich dir meine Staatsbürgerschaft irgendwie überweisen? Ich brauch die glaube ich gar nicht.
Österreicher können keine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft haben,
das ist ein Teil von unserem Stock-Konsum.
Kein Freund, kein Zug, kein König. Was habt ihr überhaupt?
Wir kommen noch zur Ibiza in dieser Sendung. Wir haben Spaß hin und wieder.
Ah, okay, das lass ich gelten, das lass ich gelten. Und die South Park Folge ist zu was?
Das war auch zu Prinz Harry und Meghan und halt deren Flucht aus dem,
aus Großbritannien und jetzt halt irgendwie wollen sie ihre Ruhe haben und sie
ziehen halt in dieser Folge in dieses Dorf wo South Park spielt und schreien die ganze Nacht,
dass sie jetzt ihre Privatsphäre haben wollen mit Feuerwerkskörpern und allem
möglichen also, wir verlinken das.
Ja man kann das aber das ist leider nicht online ne, irgendwie ist Housepark irgendwie ist, IMDB.
Aha, na gut alles klar, du suchst mal einen praktischen Link raus und wir kommen
mal zum Inhalt. Haben wir nämlich auch.
Feedback, hier geht's los. So was ist eine Shethalle? Thomas hast du schon mal gehört?
Keine Ahnung.
Shethalle.
S-H-I-D Halle. Chet heißt Schuppen und Halle heißt Halle. Schuppenhalle,
Also, zu deinem Kontext, wir haben uns ein bisschen lustig gemacht über den Namen,
weil wir den doof finden und Spoiler, ich finde den immer noch doof,
aber man lernt ja nie aus und Oberhafenjunge kommentiert, Sendung natürlich
nicht sofort gehört und es kamen schon einige Kommentare zuvor,
die grob das Konzept Chat-Halle erklären.
Nichtsdestotrotz noch einmal von mir, eine Chat-Halle bezeichnet sich normalerweise
dadurch aus, dass sie ein Shed-Dach besitzt.
Shed-Dächer, auf englisch geringfügig sperriger Sawtooth-Roof oder Sägezahndach,
sind meist mehrere Reihen von ungleich geneigten Sattel- oder Tonnendächern,
bei denen üblicherweise die steilere Dachseite verglast ist und zur Belichtung
der darunter liegenden Halle benutzt wird.
Die einzelnen Segmente eines solchen Dachs nennen sich Sheds.
Für gewöhnlich sind Shed-Dächer genordet, um über das gleichmäßige Nordlicht
ohne direkte Sonneneinstrahlung, eine blendfreie Beleuchtung der darunterliegenden Halle zu ermöglichen.
Shedhallen waren und sind im Industrie- und Gewerbebau üblich,
wenn auch viele historische Shedhallen einer kulturellen Nachnutzung zugeführt wurden.
So im Übrigen auch die Shedhalle, auf der dieser Event war, über den wir gesprochen haben.
Die Blumenberg Großhalle in Kreuzberg, heute Teil des Jüdischen Museums,
also in Berlin, ist beispielsweise solch eine Chat-Halle mit Tonnenschats,
also dann wahrscheinlich runden, die Akademie der Künstle Berlin,
Hansa-Viertel, belichtet ihre Ausstellungsräume über ein Chat-Dach.
Chat-GPT hat leider das grundlegende Merkmal des Begriffs nicht verstanden,
zeigt aber, dass man das Kicher-Potenzial von Tim und Linus nicht und erst recht
nicht den Sendungstitel von Chat-GPT generierten Definitionen abhängig machen
sollte, denn so lustig sind Chat-Hallen nicht, wenn man verstanden hat,
dass es nicht Halla Halla heißt.
All right, gut, meinetwegen, dann heißt es halt nicht Halle Halle,
trotzdem klingt Shade Halle scheiße.
Wir haben was gelernt obwohl wir es nicht wollten.
Naja so ist es ja immer, wir machen uns über alles lustig und dann kriegen wir
erzählt, dass wir total daneben gelegen haben und so weiter.
So soll es ja auch sein, so ist es ja gedacht.
Weiteres Feedback, diesmal etwas kürzer zu den Wahlen in Berlin.
Ich meinte das dann sozusagen die Legislaturperiode der jetzt gewählten Regierung in Berlin.
Wir haben ja eine neue Regierung, SPD-CDU-Regierung.
Oh Gott, immer wenn du denkst es geht nicht mehr voran, dann wird es noch schlimmer.
Eres meint, die nächste Wahl zum Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus ist in 3,5 Jahren
und nicht in zwei Jahren.
Großer Hinweis, alles richtig. Hat damit zu tun,
dass wir hier fünfjährige Legislaturperiode haben und es ja eine Nachwahl gab,
weil ja Berlin so dysfunktional ist in seiner ganzen Staatsorganisation,
dass wir da noch nicht mal ordentliche Wahlen auf die Kette kriegen.
So, jetzt seid ihr alle wieder schlauer, dank Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Noch schlauer wären wir jetzt, wenn uns Thomas mal berichtet von seinen Reisen
und der UN Cybercrime Convention,
die wir ja hier auch schon mal besprochen haben mit Khaleesi an der einen oder
anderen Stelle, aber ich denke es ist nochmal ganz wertvoll nochmal kurz drauf
zu schauen und du kannst ja mal berichten, was eigentlich dein Involvement in das Thema ist.
Kann ich gerne machen. Also, sogar die EU wird irgendwann einmal zu klein und
dann sucht man sich neue Herausforderungen.
Und in dem Fall ist es jetzt wirklich die ganze Welt.
Die Vereinten Nationen, also die UN, hat nämlich gerade Verhandlungen am Laufen,
die in Wien und New York stattfinden, zu einer neuen Konvention,
und zwar einer Konvention zu Cybercrime.
Man sollte mal grundsätzlich sagen, dass solche Konventionen relativ selten
passieren, also nur alle paar Jahrzehnte.
Und Konventionen haben zwar nicht unmittelbar einen rechtlich bindenden Charakter,
aber die Staaten, die sie ausverhandeln, ratifizieren diese Konventionen und
übersetzen sie in nationale Gesetze.
Und gerade eben zu dem Thema Cybercrime gab es bisher auf UN-Ebene noch nicht
wirklich irgendwelche Instrumente auf dieser Ebene.
Das heißt, wir reden hier von einem weltweiten Vertrag, der die Strafgesetzbücher
in ganz vielen Bereichen umschreiben könnte.
Wir haben von dem, was hier sozusagen wirklich geregelt werden sollte,
geht es einerseits darum, was ist illegal.
Das ist klassisches Hacking, also Computer-Straftatbestände,
wo sei das jetzt eben widerrechtlicher Zugriff auf ein Computersystem.
Aber es soll auch Urheberrecht hier hineinkommen. Es sollen auf jeden Fall ganz
viele analoge Straftaten,
wenn sie mit einem Computer begangen werden, auch als Cybercrime definiert werden,
was eine sehr große Ausweitung ist, also auch Fraud und alles,
was irgendwie mit Geld oder mit Kreditkarten zu tun hat.
Es gibt auch meinungsbezogene Straftatbestände, von Terrorismus angefangen,
aber auch andere aufwägerische Tatbestände sind hier davon umfasst.
Und das Wichtige ist immer, das Ganze ist ja ein weltweites Treaty,
das heißt wir können hier nicht nur von europäischen, westlichen Standards ausgehen,
sondern das hier ist wirklich, es ist nicht ein Tisch, wo die Leute sitzen,
sondern es sind sehr, sehr viele Tische in Wien, die da befüllt sind mit fast
allen der 193 Staaten dieser Welt.
Das ist auch ein ganz eigenes Klima, wie da verhandelt wird und was so die Zugänge sind.
Mit dieser Konvention werden auch Überwachungsmaßnahmen normiert.
Also wir reden hier wirklich von Echtzeitzugriff auf Metadaten,
Echtzeitzugriff auf Inhaltsdaten.
Es geht teilweise um Zugriff auf Server in Drittländern.
Das heißt, dass man auch sich direkt am Betreiber wenden kann.
Es soll auch um staatliches Hacken gehen, darum wird noch sehr stark gerungen.
Aber wir haben definitiv auch Bestimmungen jetzt im Text, die fast nicht anders
zu lesen sind, als dass hier eben Bundestrojaner, Staatstrojaner und andere Ecken und Fenster.
Eben auch in diese Konvention aufgenommen werden. Und das bedeutet,
dass Staaten dieser Welt dann eigentlich auch dazu angehalten werden,
diese Überwachungsinstrumente zu etablieren.
Und was dem Ganzen dann wirklich die Krone aufsetzt ist, dass wir hier ja von
einem weltweiten interoperablen Treaty reden.
Das heißt, das soll ja ein einheitlicher Standard über alle Länder dieser Welt
sein, der auch die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Strafverfolgungsbehörden erleichtern soll.
Sprich, wenn du eine computerbezogene Straftat in Land A hast und du glaubst,
die Verbrecher liegen in Land B, bedienen sich einer Serverfarm in Land C und
haben eine Bank in Land D, Willst du da in Zukunft viel schneller auch wirklich
gegen diese Personen vorgehen können?
Und schneller heißt aber an dieser Stelle auch, dass bestehende Rechtsschutzmechanismen,
die wir in vielen Fällen haben, damit eben ausgeschalten werden.
Es ist zum Beispiel so, dass im Moment, wenn es keine bilateralen Abkommen gibt,
Dass man dann zum Beispiel extra sorgsam mal prüfen muss, ob es hier jetzt wirklich
eine Hilfeleistung gibt aus dem anderen Land, ob ich eine Person ausliefere,
ob ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel an Russland oder an China Daten beauskunfte.
Ob ich, wenn Pakistan anfragt wegen Sexualvergehen, dann diesem Land wirklich
auch helfen will, weil vielleicht ist das, was dort illegal ist,
bei uns aus gutem Grund legal.
Wir haben im Moment so diesen Standard der Dual Criminality,
das heißt überall da, wo Land A von Land B Hilfe ersucht wegen einer Straftat,
muss jetzt mal geschaut werden, ist das denn überhaupt auch in dem anderen Land illegal.
Weil ansonsten würde ich jetzt jemanden nicht ausliefern oder da Rechtshilfe
geben, wenn in Wirklichkeit das gar nicht strafbar ist in dem Land,
wo jetzt eben die Strafverfolgungsbehörden angefragt werden, etwas zu tun.
Dann hat das Ganze natürlich nochmal spezielle Blüten, wenn China zum Beispiel
fordert, dass Fake News kriminalisiert wird.
Also, dass man wirklich falsche Informationen in der Diktion von China ist natürlich
auch mal was ganz anderes, als das in Europa zum Beispiel verstanden wird.
Wir haben einiges an Kopfschmerzen schon bekommen durch die USA,
die auf der einen Seite in Punkten verbündet,
da sind die anderen aber wirklich auf fast derselben Seite wie Russland stehen,
gerade wenn es so um Datenschutz geht, hören wir da auch von den Vertretern
der USA, dass Datenschutz ja nur yet another human right is and it shouldn't
be explicitly mentioned. Also wieso nennen wir das überhaupt?
Da haben wir so Länder wie Ägypten, die wirklich sagen so, we've counted in
the convention, there's 20 times the mention of human rights.
This is not a human rights treaty. They should all be strapped.
Also sich darüber aufregen, wie oft da irgendwie Menschenrechte vorkommen.
Und ja, Europa und europäische Länder sind tendenziell eher auf unserer Seite in den Verhandlungen.
Das Ganze hat auch ein bisschen eine Historie,
die man vielleicht erzählen könnte, weil wir haben in Europa ja die Budapest-Konvention,
also das ist ein Instrument des Europarats, also dem Teil dieser internationalen
Organisation, die größer ist als die EU.
Und diese Budapest-Konvention, die regelt schon heute, wie man mit Cybercrime
umgehen soll. Die ist aus Menschenrechtssicht durchaus problematisch.
Wir haben da auch unsere Probleme als Datenschützer damit.
Aber die setzt zu einem gewissen Standard und Länder des globalen Südens sagen
aber, gut, wir waren nicht an der Verhandlung dieses Vertrags beteiligt und
wir werden jetzt nichts zustimmen an dessen Ausverhandlung wir keine Vertragspartei waren.
Eigentlich ein sehr legitimer, korrekter Punkt, aber Russland hat dann eigentlich
diesen Prozess angestoßen,
in dem wir uns befinden, hat dann mit einigen anderen Ländern es geschafft,
dass es eine Resolution gab, die eben zu diesen Konventionsverhandlungen führt.
Das Ganze hatte seine Anfänge. 2017 ist seit einem Jahr in dem jetzigen Zustand,
mit wirklich formalen Meetings, ungefähr zwei, dreimal im Jahr.
Wir hatten gerade im April die fünfte Session, wo dann eben wirklich auch verhandelt
wird. Und man muss sich das so vorstellen, da kommen wirklich alle Länder dieser Welt zusammen.
Wir als Zivilgesellschaft dürfen ganz hinten im Saal sitzen und dann eben,
das ändert sich, wann man drankommt mit Reden,
aber wir können sozusagen Rederecht beantragen und haben dann die Möglichkeit
wirklich vor der gesamten UN zu argumentieren und wirklich auch unsere Punkte zu machen.
Ich verlinke auch die Reden, die wir da gehalten haben. Eine Kollegin Tanja
Facherthaler hat das für uns
gemacht und man hat auch die Möglichkeit Änderungsanträge einzubringen.
Das war echt cool, weil die wurden dann teilweise auch aufgegriffen und auch
von Staaten unterstützt.
Also wir haben teilweise schon einen Text vorgeschlagen, der in den jetzigen
Drafts schon übernommen wurde und ja,
also jetzt sind wir an dem Punkt, wo sozusagen am Anfang wurden alle Ideen gesammelt,
da haben alle Staaten und Multistakeholder wie wir mal irgendwie wild herumgeworfen,
was man sich nicht vorstellt.
Da gab es dann einen ersten Draft, der sehr breit war und alles irgendwie inkludiert
hat, in ein kohärentes Gerüst gepackt.
Und der wurde jetzt durchdiskutiert im Jänner und im April.
Und da haben zu jedem einzelnen dieser Textteile auch die Staaten und dann wir
als Multi-Stakeholder was sagen dürfen.
Und über den Sommer werden wir den Zero-Draft bekommen, der da schon sehr nah
an der finalen Konvention ist.
Die nächste Session ist in New York im August, da sind wir auch wieder vor Ort
und werden uns auch wieder einbringen mit Oral Interventions und Written Statements.
Kannst du mal kurz sagen, wen du meinst mit wir?
Wir sind in dem Fall jetzt Epicenter Works, wobei wir auf dem Ticket von der
Atticus Foundation dort teilnehmen, diese Registrierung bei der UNO als Stakeholder.
Es ist kein ganz so einfacher Prozess und wir haben deswegen uns da glücklicherweise
auf das Ticket von einer der Organisationen setzen können, deren Hauptmission
es ist, bei diesen Verhandlungen dabei zu sein.
Also es gibt ja recht viel formales Prozedere, man muss da akkreditiert sein,
man kriegt auch immer extra Badges, mit denen man dann auch genau an diesen
Tagen in die UN-Gebäude reinkommt, um dann wirklich auch an den Verhandlungen teilzunehmen.
Aber wir sind da nicht allein. Im Moment an den Verhandlungen beteiligt und
vor Ort sind Electronic Frontier Foundation, die da auch wirklich super Arbeit
machen, Access Now, Article
19, die drei sind auch alle eDRE Mitglied und dann noch Global Partners Digital,
der Regis Digitales, Charisma Foundation, also recht viele lateinamerikanische NGOs.
Das heißt, das ist schon so eher die globale und Global South Zivilgesellschaft.
Wir sind eigentlich die einzige europäische Netzpolitik NGO,
die da vor Ort ist und den Verhandlungen folgt. Auch Edri hat das nicht in seiner
Mission, weil das ist ja über der EU und Edri macht nur Europarat und nichts darüber hinaus.
Aber es macht halt total Sinn, dass wir hier aus einer europäischen Perspektive
auch zum Beispiel für ein Datenschutzkapitel argumentieren.
Das ist das, wo ich meinte, die USA geben uns gerade sehr viel Gegenwind,
weil aus einer europäischen Sicht ist es natürlich so,
wenn du jetzt irgendwelchen Staaten Zugriff erlaubst auf die Daten von Europäerinnen
und Europäern oder vielleicht sogar die Möglichkeit hier Funkzellenauswertung
zu machen oder auf die Server von Firmen in Europa zuzugreifen,
Vielleicht sogar wirklich bei Telekom-Operators
Fangschaltungen oder Echtzeitdatenausleitungen zu veranlassen.
Dann ist natürlich das Datenschutzniveau in diesen Ländern entscheidend dafür,
ob du diese Anfragen beantwortest oder nicht.
Und das ist aber im Moment überhaupt noch nicht gegessene Sache,
ob wir da hinkommen werden oder nicht.
Wie gesagt, wir wissen Juli, August, in welche Richtung es geht.
Das Ganze kann auch immer noch scheitern, wenn es keine Zweidrittelmehrheit
gibt unter den Staaten dieser Welt für diesen Vertrag,
dann wird er auch scheitern, dann wird er nicht angenommen und wenn er die Zweidrittelmehrheit
findet, dann ist nur noch die Frage, wer ratifiziert ihn auch.
Also die Länder müssen sich zuerst mal zu dem Vertrag bekennen,
indem sie dafür stimmen, dass das eine UN-Konvention wird.
Und das ist, wie gesagt, nur was, das passiert alle 20, 30 Jahre,
das ist dann relativ in Stein gemeißelt.
Also das ist das Kochrezept für die Überwachungsgesetze, die wir eigentlich
dann überall auf der Welt sehen werden.
Und auf die Art, wie Staaten Daten miteinander austauschen.
Und dann ist nur noch die Frage, welche Staaten ratifizieren das Ganze und welche nicht.
Und da hängt ganz viel an den USA, die im Moment ja mit dem US-Cloud-Act eher
so ein anderes System fahren,
wo sie sagen, ja, ja, ihr könnt gerne zu unseren Unternehmern kommen und dort
irgendwie die Daten abfragen, da müsst ihr nicht mehr zum FBI gehen,
aber dann wollen wir auch reziproknatürlich Zugriff auf die Server, die bei euch stehen.
Das ist so in a nutshell, was im US-Cloud-Act steht, das wäre dann auch Geschichte.
Wenn diese UN-Konvention so kommt.
Also hat wirklich sehr viel Potenzial Schaden anzurichten und hat deswegen glaube
ich auch relativ viel Aufmerksamkeit verdient.
Du hast ja gesagt Konventionen gibt es nur alle paar Jahrzehnte, stimmt so nicht ganz.
Also es gibt schon so alle paar Jahre auch mal neue UN-Konventionen,
die alle sehr unterschiedliche Popularität genießen auf diesem Planeten.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sich jetzt alle Leute solchen Konventionen,
also alle Staaten so ohne weiteres diesen Konventionen unterwerfen,
weil sie das nicht ratifizieren, wie du ja schon gesagt hast,
sondern das kann halt dauern.
Aber das ist halt so auf dem Level, es gibt so eine UN-Konvention zur Beseitigung
jeder Form von Diskriminierung der Frau.
Also das ist von 1981. Ich glaube da ist noch was zu holen. Es gibt eine UN-Konvention
gegen Folter, die öfter mal zitiert wird. Rechte der Kinder etc.
Biodiversitätskonventionen etc. pp. Das wäre halt eine solche.
Und alle paar Jahre gibt es solche Konventionen. Ich meine ich fände das in gewisser Hinsicht,
ja, was soll ich sagen,
wir wollen ja irgendwie, also Menschen können in verschiedenen Ländern leben
aber sie leben halt definitiv auf diesem Planeten und mittelfristig muss sich
ja quasi diese globale Gesellschaft in irgendeiner Form bei allen Unterschieden,
in irgendeiner Form mal einigen wie man eigentlich sozusagen auf diesem Planeten coexistieren möchte.
Es klappt bisher so, naja, so meh.
Und selbstverständlich gehören natürlich auch solche Perspektiven mit rein.
Und ich hab nur so den Eindruck, dass diese Konvention zu diesem Thema Irgendwie
so ein bisschen früher kommt als ich damit gerechnet hätte,
Wie es dir so dabei geht? Hast du damit gerechnet, dass sowas kommt?
Es war auch eigentlich immer, wenn man mit Leuten geredet hat,
die schon bei Budapest dabei waren, also das ist eben diese Council of Europe
Convention, die es da schon länger gab.
Budapester Konvention gegen Datennetzkriminalität heißt es da so schön.
Und da war eigentlich immer so die Meinung, na na, wir haben das ja und die
UN wird sowas niemals hinbekommen, die werden sich auch nie einig werden.
Dass es diesen Prozess gibt und dass der wirklich jetzt auch so viel Fahrt aufgenommen
hat und es auch wirklich, nobody blinks, it really looks like we're gonna make this.
Das heißt wirklich so eine Konvention geben wird, daran haben viele Leute gar
nicht geglaubt, dass wir jemals an diesem Punkt kommen.
Und ob das jetzt zu früh oder zu spät ist, also einige Leute sagen,
dass das schon relativ spät ist, weil natürlich ist es ein Kriminalitätsfeld,
das schon in vielen Ländern um sich gegriffen hat.
Ich will auch Strafverfolgungsbehörden überhaupt nicht absprechen,
dass es da viele Situationen gibt, wo man diesem Verbrechen nicht Herr wird,
wenn es keine internationale Kooperation gibt.
Sowohl was den total befürwortenswerten Wissensaustausch gibt,
also ich glaube wir wollen alle irgendwie Strafverfolgungsbehörden haben,
die wissen was das Internet ist und eine nicht wegschicken, somit dafür sind
wir nicht zuständig, wenn man da jetzt eine Anzeige wegen illegalen Dingen im Internet machen will.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn es dann eben um diese Überwachungsmechanismen
geht, die halt durchaus dann sehr schwer weg zu argumentieren sein werden,
wenn es dann internationalen Vertrag gibt.
Also da kann der Staat sich halt auch immer aufreden, du, darauf hat sich die
UN geeinigt, wir setzen das jetzt hier nur um.
Und dann eben gerade durch den grenzüberschreitenden Zugriff und die Anwendbarkeit dieser Maßnahmen,
glaube ich schon, dass wir eine neue Qualität hinbekommen,
wohingegen jetzt bei den anderen von dir genannten sehr wichtigen Konventionen
zum Frauenschutz, Kinderschutz und zur Folterprävention, die ja eher immer so
Vorgaben machen, die Staaten für sich umsetzen sollen.
Aber wo es nicht darum geht, dass man dann grenzüberschreitend so viel tut.
Man kann Vergleiche ziehen, das ist auch sehr gut. Dadurch schafft man einfach
auch einen Standard, an dem alle Länder zu messen sind.
Aber hier wollen ja auch wirklich die nationalen Behörden das Ganze umsetzen
und gemeinsam dann zur Anwendung bringen.
Also was siehst du denn jetzt sozusagen, mal abgesehen von eurem Aktivismus,
wo denkst du denn, muss denn sozusagen eine Aufmerksamkeit geschaffen werden
und wo muss es eine Debatte geben und welche Möglichkeiten gibt es sich daran zu beteiligen?
Also wir verlinken ganz viele Informationen,
es gibt erschreckend wenig Medienberichterstattung zu diesem Thema.
Deswegen wollte ich hier auch mal drüber sprechen, um so in den Nutshell mal
zu zeigen, was steht hier eigentlich auf dem Spiel.
Alle Dokumente sind online, auch die Recordings der Verhandlungssitzungen sind
online. Man kann sich das auch wirklich anschauen, wenn man will.
Das sind immer so zwei Wochen geblockte Verhandlungssitzungen bis früh bis spät,
also kein leichter Tobak.
Und es gibt aber eben auch die Einreichungen der Zivilgesellschaft von anderen
Institutionen, die sich hier mit uns positiv äußern.
Und insgesamt mehr Aufmerksamkeit für den Prozess ist, glaube ich, immer gut.
Es ist halt jetzt innerhalb von Europa wirklich nicht so, dass man groß etwas
ändern kann, Dadurch, dass die Staaten in Europa ja ...
Wirklich für das Gute hier stehen unter Anführungszeichen. Also es deckt sich wirklich so das,
was EFF, Access Now, Article 19 und wir so als Forderungen haben,
sehr genau mit dem, was an Forderungen jetzt von europäischen Staaten kam.
Insofern ist es halt eher so die Frage, wo findet sich die Welt denn hier?
Und da gibt es halt auch ganz unterschiedliche Zugänge.
Also wenn dann eben so die karibischen Staaten, die haben da wirklich große
Probleme teilweise mit Cybercrime und kommen aber aus einer ganz anderen rechtlichen
Tradition auf dieses Thema zu.
Insofern, ich traue mir bei dem Thema auch fast keine Prognose abzugeben,
wo wir da am Ende landen werden. Weißt du, bei EU-Themen, ich habe jetzt schon
so viele Gesetze fertig verhandelt, ich weiß ungefähr, wo es landen wird.
Okay, gut, da starten wir, das sind die Beteiligten, ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass wir da oder da landen werden.
Kann ich hier nicht. Die Erfahrungswerte fehlen mir auch.
Ich bin selber ein bisschen begeistert bei dem Prozess und versuche halt über
die Events, die wir jetzt in Wien gemacht haben, wir hatten eine große Pressekonferenz,
die verlinken wir auch, kann man nachschauen.
Und halt relativ Lobbying vor Ort, also halt wirklich mit den Vertretern der
Staaten darüber zu sprechen,
wie sie das Ganze sehen und ob man hier nicht doch vielleicht so ein bisschen
werben kann, wieso das Ganze auch nur wirklich angenommen werden kann in westlichen
Ländern, wenn man Menschenrechtsstandards inkludiert.
Wenn das kein optionales Add-on ist, sondern wirklich auch Teil der Konvention,
dann kann man sich darauf verlassen und ob sich das ausgehen wird,
im August wissen wir mehr.
Im Juni 2024 ist die UN General Assembly, wo es dann formal abgestimmt wird.
Vielleicht gibt es im Jänner 2024 noch eine letzte Verhandlungsrunde. Das ist so der Plan.
Und das findet jetzt alles immer in Wien statt oder?
Wie New York, das wechselt.
Okay, und wie viele Veranstaltungen waren das jetzt bisher?
Also im April war die fünfte offizielle Verhandlungsrunde, das sind immer zwei
Wochen, wo von früh bis spät eben alle zusammenkommen.
Es ist hybrid, aber der Großteil der Leute sind vor Ort. Und dann gibt es eben
die Möglichkeit, für die Staaten mal Stellung zu nehmen und wann auch immer
der Chair es erlaubt, können eben auch wir als Multi-Stakeholder sprechen.
Das war manchmal am Ende jedes Kapitels, manchmal erst nach einem Cluster,
also dann hast du teilweise nur alle paar Tage, wo du sprechen kannst.
Aber es ist alles öffentlich, also du weißt wirklich genau, wo welcher Staat steht.
Es gibt dann so lustige Situationen, wo der Vatikan dafür argumentiert,
dass man auf jeden Fall den Begriff Kinderpornografie erhalten sollte und Dokumentation
von Kindesmissbrauch ist ja viel zu unkonkret.
Oder die USA. Es sind wirklich sehr skurrile Blüten, die man da mitbekommt und
das Orge ist aber, die Leute sind relativ zugänglich.
Also wenn man menschlichen Draht zu ihnen aufbaut, kann man durchaus eben Dinge mitgeben.
Manche Staaten sind auch sehr gesprächig und sagen auch relativ offen,
wie sie den Prozess wahrnehmen, wie sie andere Staaten wahrnehmen.
Es war ein bisschen transparent, dass ich das bisher im Rat der EU erlebt habe,
wo alle immer so, das sind so die Beamten, die sich so ein bisschen wegducken
und das dort sind halt eher die Diplomaten, die halt auch auf einer menschlichen
Ebene es gewohnt sind zu reagieren, wenn man auf sie zugeht, ja, ist ganz spannend.
Kannst du mir mal so ein Feeling dafür geben, wie so ein Lobby,
so eine Lobby-Situation real aussieht?
Also du bist jetzt irgendwie ja auch nicht jeden Tag dabei, sondern ihr habt
irgendwie euch beworben da zu sprechen? Ja?
Naja, du bist, wenn du für die Session akkreditiert bist, hast du einen Pass,
der diese vollen zwei Wochen, die erlaubt hat, dabei zu sein.
Und wir teilen es uns auf, also meine Kollegin und ich,
weil die ganze Zeit, alle zwei Wochen ist sehr heftig,
aber es ist immer jemand von uns da, eben auch weil wir nicht wissen,
wann wir reden, dass wir halt einfach immer reagieren können und dann hast du unter den NGOs,
teilst du dir mal auf, wer macht nur das Monitoring,
wer schaut vielleicht, wer gerade im Raum ist und versucht,
zum Beispiel dann, wir haben immer so ein Mapping, wo wir versuchen zuzuordnen,
durch den gesamten Text der Konvention, was wird dazu gesagt von den einzelnen
Staaten und wo gibt es vielleicht Bruchlinien, an denen man arbeiten kann.
Und die eigentlichen Gespräche mit den Vertretern der Staaten machst du dann
auf Basis von diesem Wissen, dass du entweder auf einer inhaltlichen Ebene gleich
kommst, dass du sagst so, Das und das sehen wir übrigens so und wirklich in
der Sache kommentierst.
Das kann auch sein, we would like to understand, also du versuchst irgendwie,
auch wenn du, du ess keine Kritik, aber du versuchst halt immer so ein Gespräch
aufzubauen und indem du sie verstehst auch Verständnis für deine Position zu schaffen.
Ganz viel ist dann aber auch eben so auf einer menschlichen Ebene.
Wir haben zum Beispiel eben einige Leute aus Lateinamerika da und da ist es immer super easy,
weil die mit den Leuten aus recht vielen Ländern dann in ihrer Muttersprache sprechen können.
Genauso auch Raman, der Kollege von Access Now aus Indien und wir haben halt
eher so die europäischen Länder, auf die wir uns fokussieren.
Teilweise eben auch USA und Neuseeland, Australien, die auch sehr wichtig sind
für diesen Prozess und dann schaust du halt, dass du mit den Leuten ins Gespräch
kommst und halt clever deine Punkte platzierst.
Es gibt da jetzt wenig, was unausgesprochen ist, bis auf die Sachen,
von denen du ausgehst, dass sie irgendwann später passieren.
Also schlägt noch ein Staat irgendwie vor, dass man vielleicht zum Beispiel,
was die EU gemacht hat, was uns überrascht hat, Dass du die Überwachungsmethoden...
Entkoppelst von den Kriminalitätsbestimmungen, dass du sagst,
okay, ich definiere zwar hier, was illegal sein soll, dann definiere ich,
welche Maßnahmen ich zur Verbrechensbekämpfung habe,
aber die sind nicht one-on-one miteinander verlinkt, sondern alles über einer
gewissen Strafhöhe kann zum Beispiel die Metadatenausleitung von einem Telco
beantragen und nicht nur die gelisteten Straftatbestände.
Das hat uns überrascht. Das war was, das sie angeboten haben dafür,
dass es ein Datenschutzkapitel gibt zum Beispiel.
Also diese Abtausche, die Staaten machen.
Das ist ganz schwierig zu antizipieren und das sind auch gut gehütete Geheimnisse.
Aber ja, wie gesagt, es ist auch für mich wirklich noch mal was Neues,
so in diesem Prozess dabei zu sein, weil UNO hatten wir vorher einfach noch nicht.
Und du hast halt vor allem auch zwar Verhandler aus all diesen Staaten da,
aber viele der Entscheidungen werden dann trotzdem in den Hauptstädten getroffen
und sind eher so die Einschätzungen,
die du mitgeben kannst und vielleicht einen Eindruck, aber ein wirkliches Überzeugen,
dass das die richtige oder falsche Position ist, die Entscheidung wird nicht im Saal getroffen.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, du redest mit einem Land, also wie viele Leute sind denn
das da pro Land, die da irgendwie präsent sind?
Also es sind, ich glaube keine Delegation reist alleine an.
Vielleicht die ganz kleinen Länder, aber die meisten sind zumindest zu zweit, zu dritt.
Deutschland ist zum Beispiel mit fünf Leuten da, die USA glaube ich auch so
mit fünf oder sieben und Österreich sind glaube ich nur zwei oder drei Leute,
obwohl das ja für die ein Heimspiel ist.
Es gibt auch Funding der UNO für kleinere Staaten da überhaupt hinzukommen,
das ist nicht selbstverständlich.
China ist glaube ich wirklich nur mit einer oder zwei Personen da und das ist auch ganz lustig,
weil die liest alles ab, was sie sagt, da ist sozusagen das Handy vorm Gesicht,
liest auf Chinesisch vor, hat aber die Übersetzung im Ohr und schaut eigentlich
nur, dass es richtig wiedergegeben wird auf Englisch für die anderen.
Und ja, relativ wenige Staaten lassen sich zuschalten. Also das ist wirklich die Minderheit.
Kommt vielleicht alle 20, 30 Wortmeldungen mal vor, dass jemand remote zugeschalten
wird. Der Großteil der Staaten, die sprechen, sind auch wirklich vor Ort.
Und jetzt kannst du mal, was wäre
das, ich Österreich, hast du gesagt Österreich ist wie in Deutschland?
Es waren zwei, drei Leute. Also die Delegation, die bestellt wurde,
sind sieben Leute. Das haben wir nachgeschaut, aber jetzt wirklich vor Ort gesehen.
Ich hoffe, ich verpätze jetzt niemanden. Habe ich wirklich nur so,
glaube ich, eher zwei, drei Leute.
Was mich mal interessieren würde, ist, wie sind diese Delegationen zusammengesetzt?
Also was sind das für Leute?
Das sind alles Leute aus den Ministerien. Das ist eigentlich immer Außen- und
Justizministerium, teilweise auch Innenministerium.
Also das sind Leute, die Law Enforcement Corporation machen,
also die auch bilaterale Abkommen für Strafrechtskooperationen verhandeln.
Das sind Leute, die sich um Strafrecht kümmern in den Mitgliedstaaten.
Teilweise sind es Staatsanwälte, teilweise sind es Polizistinnen,
teilweise sind es Diplomaten.
Wir haben relativ viele Cyberbotschafter vor Ort, das gibt es ja inzwischen
auch, es gibt Botschafter fürs Internet.
Du hast dann zum Beispiel auch Interpol hier vor Ort,
das ist auch ganz lustig, ich glaube,
das kann ich an dieser Stelle sagen, aber es war auch ganz lustig,
da waren wir mal irgendwie nach diesen, es gibt da auch so Kleingruppen,
gewisse Themen werden ausgelagert in Kleingruppen, wo die Staaten dann abseits
des Plenums nicht öffentlich verhandeln.
Aber als Ausgleich dafür, dass das nicht öffentlich ist, gibt es dann so kleine
Debriefings, wo man sich in einen Call hängen kann und dann kriegt man sozusagen
die Infos von den Verhandlern, worüber geredet wird und kann halt auch wiederum Input liefern.
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass alles gehört wird dort und danach handelt es eine
andere Frage, aber man wird gehört.
Und ich war halt irgendwie auch mal in so einem Call und genau mit seinem Rücken
zu mir sitzt der Vertreter von Interpol und ich drehe mich dann halt irgendwann
um nach dem Call und wollte nur Hallo sagen und sehe so richtig,
wie er die Screenshots von dem Call, wo er die NGO-Leute eingekreist hat,
dann per Signal weiterschickt an seine Kollegen.
Also die machen schon auch teilweise Opposition Research dort,
aber du hast natürlich, die Strafverfolgungsbehörden,
für die ist das vested interest, das ist das Spielfeld, auf dem sie dann die
nächsten Jahre, Jahrzehnte gemeinsam kooperieren können oder eben auch nicht.
Für die ist es auf jeden Fall ein ganz ganz wichtiger ganz wichtiges Thema und
so wie bei allem was aus dem Innenministerium kommt, da muss man halt auch aus
Menschenrechtssicht draufschauen.
Also jetzt diese fünf Sessions gab es und die letzte ist jetzt in Wien gewesen,
war zwei Wochen gedauert und die ist jetzt wann zu Ende gegangen?
Das war im April.
Und dann kommt noch eine wievielte?
Also im Grunde gibt es eine fix angesetzte Session im August in New York.
Es ist auch avisiert im Jänner eine in New York und dann sollte der Vertrag eigentlich stehen,
weil der muss auch übersetzt werden in alle Sprachen, damit er auf der UN-Vollversammlung
im Juni 2024 dann abgestimmt werden kann. Das ist der Zeitplan.
Bis dahin muss man sich eigentlich auch einig werden. Im Moment ist es nicht ganz klar,
wie so eine Einigung ausschaut, weil Staaten haben halt in den letzten Sessions
sehr stark gesagt, was ihre roten Linien sind und die sind eigentlich nicht
sehr gut miteinander vereinbar.
Also da jetzt den Mittelweg zu finden, auf den man sich einigen kann,
ist eine Herausforderung für den Chair.
Der Chair ist eine algerische Diplomatin, die das sehr geschickt managt.
Ich traue da schon zu, etwas vorzulegen, aber man wird es dann halt sehen,
ob das auch in der Gesamtwetterlage funktioniert.
Weil du hast zum Beispiel, es war
ja wirklich erst im Jänner diesen Jahres angefangen haben zu verhandeln,
es war so, dass jedes Land irgendwie begonnen hat, nicht jedes,
aber viele Länder, vor allem viele westliche Länder, haben halt den Russland
verurteilt wegen dem Ukraine Krieg.
Und es ist da schon sehr aufgeladen. Und wenn man weiß, dass Russland das Ganze
initiiert hat, dass es überhaupt so einen Vertrag gibt, ja, aber wie gesagt,
die sind da nicht alleine.
Es gibt auch Länder des globalen Südens, die sehr berechtigt sagen, wir brauchen so etwas.
Und es wäre ein bisschen billig, wenn man jetzt sagt, so wir sind jetzt als
Europäer dagegen, weil wir haben ja eh unsere Instrumente, die für uns funktionieren.
Gut, super, also tolle Sache, aber nach New York fährst du dann nicht?
Es wird auf jeden Fall jemand von uns aus New York dabei sein,
aber wahrscheinlich macht das meine Kollegin Tanja, die auch hauptsächlich da
für uns gesprochen hat die meiste Zeit.
Die hat auch früher mal bei der UNO gearbeitet, bevor sie bei uns war und sie
ist da wirklich wie ein Fisch im Wasser. Seht ihr das?
So wie alles bei uns, Tim, spenden. Wir haben dafür keinerlei Grants oder sowas bekommen,
bei New York wird's halt irgendwie ein Airbnb oder sowas, um da billiger unterzukommen,
aber wir wissen noch nicht, ob wir alle zwei Wochen schaffen werden oder nur
eine oder nur vier Tage, aber wir sind auf jeden Fall dort.
Und die restliche Zeit schauen wir, dass wir uns zuschalten. Und ja.
Und das Schaffen hängt von Zeit ab oder von Geld ab?
Das hängt vom Geld ab. Also New York ist wirklich scheiße teuer.
Also in anderen Worten, wenn genug Kohle da ist für die Aktion,
dann nehmt ihr auch vollständig dran teil.
Ja auf jeden Fall. Also da noch die vollen zwei Wochen.
Muss man ja auch mal sagen. Ich meine das ist ja schon eine extreme Anstrengung,
die weitgehend unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet.
Also der Medienöffentlichkeit, du hast ja schon beklagt, dass da so viel nicht
drüber berichtet wird und trotzdem gibt es halt Aktivisten,
die sich da die Zeit nehmen, das Ganze zu begleiten und zu diskutieren,
das Ganze aus der Perspektive der Gesellschaft und eben nicht der Staaten und
das finde ich eine wichtige Aktion.
Gut, dann gucken wir doch nochmal, was wir noch so auf unserem Themenzettel haben.
Du wolltest uns auch nochmal zu den Verhandlungen von EIDAS was berichten.
Genau, wir hatten das Thema ja schon. Also wir kommen in die EU und wir haben
ja schon mal in der Sendung über EIDAS gesprochen, über dieses neue EU-Gesetz,
das digitale Identitäten regeln soll.
Und wie schon mal ausgeführt, mit diesem Gesetz kommt eine European Digital Identity Wallet.
So nennt sich eine App, die laut den Vorstellungen der EU-Kommission bald auf
unser aller Telefonen sein soll,
mit der wir uns elektronisch ausweisen können gegenüber Dritten,
sowohl staatlichen Einrichtungen wie auch privaten Firmen.
Das Ganze soll auch dazu dienen, rechtsgültig Verträge zu unterschreiben.
Führerschein soll man darüber vorweisen können. Und auch Covid-Zertifikate, also Covid-Impfungen.
Aber eben auch einen Altersnachweis soll man über diese EIDAS-Wallet nahe erbringen können.
Und wie schon mal ausgeführt, das Ganze ist halt aus Datenschutzsicht wirklich
hochproblematisch, weil damit identifizieren super einfach und vor allem gratis wird.
Das ist es ja im Moment nicht. Wenn ich Leute im Moment irgendwie elektronisch
rechtsgültig identifizieren will, dann zahle ich da halt doch irgendwie einen
ein- bis zweistelligen Eurobetrag dafür.
Und mit so einem Instrument könnte das viel alltäglicher werden,
dass wir wirklich unsere bürgerliche Identität hergeben.
Und nachdem auch ganz viele Gesundheitsdaten bald in dieser Wallet landen werden,
gibt es auch wirklich die Gefahr, dass über uns Informationen angefragt werden,
die wir sonst vielleicht nur mit dem Arzt teilen würden.
Zum Beispiel, welche Allergien man hat oder welche genetischen Prädispositionen
oder auch Impfstatus und solche Dinge.
Ja, das ist immer noch sozusagen die Ausgangsbasis gewesen, dass man hier sehr
viele Risiken eigentlich hat und versucht, aber denen mit Safeguards Herr zu werden.
Wie gesagt, das Gesetz komplett abzulehnen, wäre politisch nie und nimmer durchgegangen,
vor allem auch, weil ja hier Google und Apple schon in den Startlöchern stehen.
In der EU es immer so diesen Zugang gibt, solange wir eine Lösung machen,
ist die immer besser, als wenn sie aus Silicon Valley kommt.
Auch ein Zugang, den ich irgendwie nachvollziehen kann. Aber ja,
nichtsdestotrotz, dieses Gesetz ist jetzt in den letzten Zügen.
Wir müssen hier wieder mal kurz erklären, wie die EU funktioniert,
weil wir befinden uns gerade in dem schwierigsten Teil von EU-Gesetzgebung,
dem sogenannten Trilog.
Also, Kommission.
Ich will erklären. Mach du, mach du.
Also Vorschlagsrecht hat immer die Kommission, die sind sozusagen diejenigen
die sich denken da müsste man mal was machen. So das Parlament kann darauf nur
reagieren, kann das diskutieren, kann sich eine Meinung dazu bilden,
das tut sie in den Ausschüssen.
In diesen Ausschüssen werden dann im Wesentlichen die Position des Parlaments
erarbeitet als Antwort auf den Vorschlag der Kommission.
Und letztlich geht es aber in den Trilog und da kommt dann halt diese dritte
Entität der EU, die immer gerne vergessen und auch vor allem gerne verwechselt wird.
Wir hatten ja vorhin schon den Europarat erwähnt. Ja es gibt den Europarat außerhalb
der EU, aber es gibt halt auch noch den European Council der EU und das ist
eben quasi die Vertretungsgruppe der Staaten, also der Regierungen,
der aktuellen Regierungen.
Und die haben dann immer noch ein Wörtchen mitzureden. Und erst wenn die drei
sich dann hinter verschlossenen Türen auf einen Kompromiss geeinigt haben,
dann kann das Ding abgesignet werden.
Ganz genau.
Und wir haben halt schon sozusagen Kommission hat vorgestellt,
Parlament hat seine Meinung, seine Version des Gesetzes, der Rat,
die Mitgliedstaaten hat seine Version des Gesetzes, jetzt müssen die drei sich einig werden.
Und hier ist es so, dass an diesem Gesetz gerade sehr intensiv verhandelt wird.
Also wir haben, glaube ich, zwei bis drei Arbeitssitzungen jede Woche.
Und dann wird die ganze Zeit eben über den Text drüber gegangen.
Man versucht irgendwie Lösungen zu finden. Im Moment liegen die Verhandlungen
noch relativ weit voneinander entfernt.
Im Moment ist so das Thema Unique Persistent Identifier, also diese eindeutige
Kennnummer, die hier kommen soll, die in Deutschland verfassungswidrig wäre,
wie wir immer wieder betonen.
Die ist gerade ein Stein des Anstoßes. Worüber noch gestritten wird,
ist die Frage, naja, welche Firmen können hier eigentlich mitspielen?
Und was tun wir denn, wenn eine Firma Schindluder betreibt? Also kann man jemanden
ausschließen von diesem Ökosystem, dieser digitalen Wallet?
Kann eine Firma, die hier zugelassen ist, alles anfragen?
Oder müssen Datenanfragen erst freigeschalten werden? Zum Beispiel,
dass man Gesundheitsdaten nur dann anfragen darf, wenn man einen legitimen Use-Case
dafür hat. Wenn man auch Datenschutzfolgeabschätzung gemacht hat,
wie es die DSGVO vorschreiben würde.
Über diese Details wird gerade noch gestritten.
Und im Moment haben wir gerade eine schwedische Ratspräsidentschaft,
das wechselt ja immer jedes halbe Jahr.
Ab Juli sind dann die Spanier dran und ich rechne damit, dass wir dieses Jahr
ein fertiges Gesetz bekommen werden.
Ich glaube nicht mehr, dass es sich noch unter den Schweden ausgehen wird,
aber es machen einige Stakeholder enormen Druck, dass man hier schnell fertig wird.
Noch hält das Parlament die Linie?
Und es ist aber eben in diesem Rhythmus jetzt alle paar Tage kommen neue Gesetzestexte.
Ein Großteil davon schafft den Weg dann auch zu uns. Wir dürfen unsere Meinung
sagen, dürfen teilweise auch Vorschläge machen.
Und dann versucht man halt irgendwie die Mehrheit im Parlament zusammenzuhalten
für einen guten Text, der sich dann im besten Fall auch noch durchsetzen muss
gegenüber dem, was die Mitgliedsstaaten so sagen.
Und die Kommission, das ist auch ganz spannend, die ist ja eigentlich gar keine Vertragspartei hier,
also die sitzen zwar mit im Raum und die dürfen auch was sagen,
aber eigentlich müssen sich nur Parlament und Rat einig werden,
damit es ein Gesetz wird, weil die beiden müssen ja am Ende auch noch darüber abstimmen.
Die Kommission kann ja nicht Ja oder Nein sagen, wenn die nicht happy sind mit
dem, was da beschlossen wird. Bad luck.
Sie haben das Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht, aber sie können nicht am Ende die Reißleine ziehen.
Und Khaleesi hat ja eh schon mal irgendwie diese tolle Serie empfohlen, The Parliament.
Da sieht man das in der zweiten Staffel auch recht gut und das ist wirklich
sehr realistisch dargestellt.
Am Ende, wenn sich die Mitgliedsstaaten an das Parlament einig sind,
ist es wurscht, was die Kommission sagt. In der Praxis ist es aber eher umgekehrt.
Wenn die Kommission sich auf die Seite von Parlament oder Rat stellt,
dann hat die andere Seite meistens verloren.
Und genau in diesem Verhandlungstreik sind wir jetzt gerade und ich hoffe,
dass so die roten Linien von uns erhalten bleiben. Das ist das ganz Wichtigste
an der Nichtdiskriminierungsregel.
Also Leute, die diese Wallet nicht verwenden wollen, sollen in keiner Weise
Nachteile erfahren dürfen. Es muss verboten sein, Leute schlechter zu behandeln,
nur weil sie diese Wallet nicht haben.
Das Zweite, was uns ganz wichtig ist, ist, dass die Unbeobachtbarkeit gewahrt
ist, dass nicht irgendwer zentral zuschauen kann, welche Social-Media-Services
ich nutze, wo ich einkaufen gehe, gegenüber wem ich mein Impfzertifikat vorzeige.
Und zuletzt natürlich auch, dass man irgendeine Handhabe hat gegen Fraudulent
Use Cases, also wenn die Wallet verwendet wird entgegen dem Interesse der Nutzer,
wenn betrogen wird damit, wenn Identitätsdiebstahl passiert.
Und zuletzt können wir nur alle beten, dass dieses Ding irgendwie sicher bleibt,
weil die Sicherheit ist komplett ausgelagert auf Rechtsakte,
die erst später kommen und Zertifizierungen, von denen wir heute noch nichts wissen.
Und ich glaube, dass hier viele Hackerinnen und Hacker noch sehr viel Spaß damit haben werden.
Ich meine, du musst dir nur vorstellen, das sind die Finanz-,
Gesundheits- und Identitätsdaten von Hunderten von Millionen Menschen in einem einzigen System.
Also der Tech-Surface ist riesig von den Dingen.
Aber ja, da stehen wir gerade.
Alles klar. Ja, ich bin gespannt was da für Standards rauskommen.
Ich meine, als meintest du irgendwie, wir wollen das nicht von Silicon Valley definieren lassen.
Ich habe manchmal so den Eindruck, dass Silicon Valley das irgendwie mit den
Standards noch ein bisschen besser versteht, so wie das eigentlich zu funktionieren hat.
Ich will mir jetzt nicht gleich glauben, dass es mal wieder alles so auf der
Qualität deutscher Ministerien läuft. sobald dann werden wir verloren.
Ja, also was erschreckend ist, ist wie wenig technischer Sachverstand dort am Tisch sitzt.
Also es gibt einen Experten von der EU-Kommission, der da immer im Raum ist
und ansonsten sind es eigentlich nur politisch besetzte Leute.
Und wenn man sich, ein Bekannter von unserem Verein, der bei uns auch Mitglied ist, hat
diesen ISO Mobile Driving License Standard mitverhandelt und kommt halt aus
der IT Security und der kriegt glaube ich wirklich graue Haare durch das was
ich ihm da die ganze Zeit erzähle.
Und das ist halt kein technikgetriebener Prozess um es freundlich zu sagen.
Jetzt bin ich richtig beruhigt, kann ja gar nichts schief gehen,
ist ja eigentlich für alles gesorgt.
Ja keine Garantie für das für das Resultat, wobei ich glaube immer noch wir
haben eine reale Chance auf ein gutes Gesetz, also auf eines das zumindest mal
Safeguards beinhaltet, dass das Ding ordentlich umgesetzt werden kann.
Ob es dann am Ende schief geht, da müssen wir,
also es wird zumindest die Template-Implementierung Open Source sein,
wenn es nach uns geht auch die komplette Software Open Source,
zumindest die, die die Wallet begründet, nicht die von dem Common Interface,
das so der Klebstoff zwischen den einzelnen Teilen ist, also wir hoffen,
dass wir zumindest dann wirklich auch neutral auf Basis der bestehenden Systeme
das auch analysieren können.
Es gibt inzwischen auch schon erste technische Spezifikationen,
die wir auch analysiert haben, aber die sind alle noch sehr unterkomplex.
Also man sieht, dass da die Gruppe, die das Ganze technisch implementieren soll,
ist auch locker eineinhalb Jahre hinter dem jetzigen Verhandlungsstand.
Und am Ende muss man es natürlich an der Implementierung bemessen,
nicht an den guten Ideen und politischen Versprechen.
Aber politische Versprechen bringt uns vielleicht auch gleich zu Netzneutralität, oder?
Genau. Ein mittelgroßes Thema haben wir noch auf der Liste, nämlich dein Lieblingsthema.
Ist da irgendwas passiert?
Ja, ich bin ja Mr. Netzneutralität. Ich habe gedacht, ich kann in den Ruhestand
gehen und es ist alles erledigt.
Und dann vor einem Jahr im Mai hat die eigentlich von mir geschätzte Kommissarin
Vestager sich auf die Seite irgendwo ihres Kollegen Thierry Petain gestellt
und befürwortet ja seitdem diese Idee der Netzgebühren, der sogenannten Fair-Share-Abgabe.
Was ist damit gemeint? Naja, es ist gemeint, dass man die Geschäftsmodelle der
Telefon-Ära über das Internet drüberstülpt,
indem man das Funktionieren des Kabels im Internet,
von dem, was die ISBs wie die Deutsche Telekom uns allen verkaufen,
Da reicht es nicht mehr, wenn wir als Nutzer dafür zahlen, dass wir ins Internet
dürfen, sondern die, die uns erreichen wollen, müssen jetzt auch zahlen dafür,
dass wir sie erreichen dürfen.
Also es soll eine Netzgebühr bei den Inhalteanbietern eingehoben werden,
vornehmlich mal nur bei den großen Inhalteanbietern.
Wenn man da näher hinschaut, sieht man aber, dass ganz viele öffentlich-rechtliche
und private Medien hier mit betroffen sind,
ganz viele Angebote von der öffentlichen Hand, E-Learning und so weiter,
die auf Cloud-Anbietern hosten, die natürlich hier zahlen müssten.
Auch Pornografie natürlich, so Dinge wie Hetzen, also europäische Hosting-Anbieter
werden von ihrem Traffic-Volumen her natürlich auch groß genug hier betroffen zu sein.
Also grob ist so die Rede von allen Inhalteanbietern, die mehr als sieben Prozent
der Netzlast ausmachen, sollen zur Kasse gebeten werden.
Und wer hier nicht zahlt, kriegt einfach keine Interconnection Agreements mehr,
also keine Zusammenschaltung zwischen den Netzen, die das Internet ausmachen.
Und das ist halt eine radikale Abkehr von dem, was das Internet heute zusammenhält
und immer schon zusammengehalten hat.
Denn es gibt einen guten Grund, wieso diese Zusammenschaltung im Internet großteils
auf Handschlägen passiert.
Da gibt es nicht mal schriftliche Verträge, weil Leute sich gedacht haben,
dass wir ein Netz haben, wo alle einander erreichen, ist mehr wert,
als dass wir jetzt irgendwie hier die Bits zählen und uns gegenseitig Rechnungen stellen.
Es wird ja auch nicht wirklich der Traffic, also der Datenverkehr abgerechnet
im Interconnection-Markt, sondern eigentlich nur die Kapazitäten.
So, du brauchst einen neuen 10 Gigabit-Port von A nach B, okay gut,
dann zahlst für den Port, aber nicht über das, was dann wirklich an Datenvolumen darüber fließt.
So ist es zumindest in vielen Fällen so.
Ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Diese Idee wird jetzt seit einem Jahr diskutiert
und die Gefahr ist leider ungebannt.
Ich war erst letztens wieder in Brüssel auf einem Panel mit der Kommission.
Wir haben auch gerade eine öffentliche Konsultation, Also eine Begutachtung,
ein Konsultationsverfahren, wo man sich noch bis zum 19.
Mai äußern kann zu dieser Idee einer Netzgebühr.
Wir haben da auch einen kleinen Guide veröffentlicht.
Wer sich da beteiligen will, kann das auf Basis von dem Dokument ganz einfach machen.
Das wäre auch wirklich, wenn ihr irgendwas mit Internet zu tun habt,
wenn ihr eine Firma habt, wenn ihr einen Verein habt, wenn euer Hackerspace
da einen Hauch politisch ist, wäre es wirklich toll, wenn aus der Community
noch mehr Menschen dieser Idee eine Absage erteilen könnten.
Und wir sehen, dass die Telekom-Industrie sehr stark mobilisiert für diese Konzertation.
Wir versuchen dagegen zu halten. Es gab erst vor kurzem einen offenen Brief,
den wir gemacht haben mit über 50 Organisationen, aber der kleinste Teil davon waren NGOs.
Es war großteils so, ich würde sagen, unlikely allies. Zum Beispiel die Urheberrechtsindustrie.
Wir haben es geschafft, dass wir wirklich so die größten Sportrechteverbände,
die privaten Medienanstalten, die Hollywoods dieser Welt, die Zeitungsverleger
haben sich schon kritisch geäußert.
Mit dem Brief haben wir es auch geschafft, dass die Spieleindustrie sich mal
hier klar dagegen positioniert.
Und die vielen ganz kleinen Telekom Betreiber haben auch gesagt,
eigentlich haben wir nichts davon, wenn die Deutsche Telekom und Orange jetzt
hier fett abkassieren, das schadet uns eher nur im Wettbewerb,
weil die haben ja viel mehr Kunden und kriegen dadurch viel mehr Geld.
Also da gibt es inzwischen eine riesige Latte an Positionspapieren.
Ich verlinke da noch eine Übergesichtsseite, wo man die einsehen kann.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die Kommission ist weiterhin der Meinung,
dass es das braucht, damit wir die Breitbandausbauziele erreichen.
Nämlich bis 2030 irgendwelche Gigabits ins Feld zu führen, Tim kannst du dich
erinnern an irgendein Breitband Ausbau Ziel was jemals erreicht wurde?
Also du bist nicht in Deutschland.
Es mag in anderen Ländern ja anders sein, aber das ist halt einfach immer wieder diese selbe Schose,
ja wir brauchen mehr Netz und dann so die großen Stakeholder in diesem Bereich jammern so,
das ist aber alles so teuer, die Kohle herkriegen und so weiter und wollen sich
das halt sozusagen von der vorne und von hinten und von links und von rechts
dreifach, vierfach, fünffach bezahlen lassen.
Von den Kunden, von den gehosteten Unternehmen, von den Kunden sozusagen,
also von den Nutznießern auf der zweiten und dritten Ebene,
Wir hatten das ja auch schon mal Leitungsschutzrecht genannt,
so ein Hand aufhalten ist,
nur all diese ganzen Maßnahmen, die tragen nicht dazu bei,
das einzige was dazu beiträgt ist halt ein freier Wettbewerb und der kann halt
einfach nur stattfinden,
wenn man irgendwie diese ganze last mile einfach kommunalisiert und sagt so,
Der Zugang zu den Leuten in dem Haus, wo der, naja, der muss sozusagen jedem
Unternehmen offen stehen.
Und dann machen es halt auch nicht mehr diese Unternehmen, sondern andere bauen
irgendwie diese Zugänge.
Und darüber kann man eine ganze Menge Geld kanalisieren und diesen Infrastrukturausbau
schaffen, um solche Angebote zu machen, dann ist der ganze Interconnect am Ende
auch nicht mehr das Problem, weil es gibt genug Glasfaser.
Absolut. Also ich meine die Netze haben ja in Corona auch gehalten und auch
die Last Mile und im Interconnection ist es so billig auszubauen.
Und die Datenvolumen steigen ja bei weitem nicht mehr so stark wie sie das früher
gemacht haben. Im Gegenteil, wir sehen eine Sättigung des Marktes.
Die meisten Leute haben halt jetzt gerade schon ihre ein bis zweieinhalb Internetanschlüsse
und ich meine, wie viele Leute haben einen 4K-Fernseher?
Also irgendwann einmal ist auch wirklich so die Sättigung erreicht.
Wir sehen, dass die Netzzentralität in Europa hält.
Da gab es auch jetzt Ende April einen Report der EU-Kommission,
der ist gesetzlich vorgeschrieben. Die müssen sozusagen offiziell sagen,
wollen wir an dem Thema was machen, ja oder nein? Und die Antwort ist nein.
Netzzentralität bleibt, also Zero-Rating bleibt verboten.
Bezahlte Überholspuren, also Spezialdienste, bleiben stark eingeschränkt.
Und Blocken und Drosseln geht sowieso nicht mehr.
Also der Teil ist gesichert. Das bleibt auch sicherlich mal die nächsten drei bis vier Jahre so.
Dann werden wir wahrscheinlich wieder darüber streiten müssen.
Wahrscheinlich unter irgendwelchen 5G, 6G-Argumenten vorgeschobenen.
Aber dieser Kampf ist jetzt so...
Der Weg, wie diese großen Telekom-Unternehmen, die Big-Telcos,
noch einmal aufgebären, doch bitteschön die Welt und das Geschäftsmodell des
Internets umzukrempeln, damit es für sie einfacher wird.
Und Digitalkommissar Thierry Pétain war halt früher mal Chef von Orange, von France Telecom.
Der ist ihr bester Mann. Der ist jetzt gerade noch genau in der Position,
dass er ihnen helfen kann. Und der probiert alles, was er kann.
Und deswegen muss man ihn stoppen. Wenn wir es schaffen, dass wir kein Gesetz
bekommen von ihm bis September, Oktober diesen Jahres, dann sind wir safe für
diese Gesetzgebungsperiode.
Und im Mai wird gewählt, da ist danach keine Zeit mehr für so etwas.
Also man muss jetzt diese Begutachtung wirklich noch kampanisieren,
möglichst viel Sachverstand, Nördverstand da mit in die Debatte einfließen lassen.
Und dann hoffen, dass es reicht und dass alles irgendwie mit rechten Mitteln
zugeht. Also ich meine, es ist im Moment wirklich beachtlich,
wie viel Widerstand es gibt.
Deutschland hat sich ja klar positioniert, die Niederlande, Finnland,
Belgien, Dänemark und Österreich auch.
Da haben wir überall schon Aussagen, dass wir das eigentlich für eine schlechte Idee halten.
Und jetzt geht es halt um die letzten paar Monate noch, Weil ich gehe davon
aus, dass Breton das schon längst vorgeschlagen hätte, diese Idee an der Netzgebühr,
wenn er Einstimmigkeit unter seinen KollegInnen in der EU-Kommission hätte.
Da braucht er nämlich Einstimmigkeit für neue Gesetze.
Solange er die nicht hat, sind wir safe.
Und das ist jetzt gerade so das Spiel, sobald wir das irgendwie geschafft haben
weiterhin im Port zu enthalten, können wir das mit der Netz-Neutralität hoffentlich
endlich mal abhaken. Ich will was anderes machen.
Ich fühle mit dir.
Das ist zu lang. Ich gehe in den Ruhestand.
Na gut.
Gute Nachricht.
Ja, Moment.
Wer da mit?
Juhu! Die Wiener Hacking-Firma DS-IRF ist heute, as we speak,
8. Mai hops gegangen und stellt alle ihre Geschäfte ein.
Aha.
Ähm ...
Erzähl mal, was ist denn DS-IRF?
DS-IRF ist der Hersteller der Spionagesoftware SubZero oder NotWeed.
Das ist ein Staatstrojaner, der auf Windows-Geräten sich unbemerkt einlistet
und dann das klassische Repertoire,
Bildschirminhalt abfotografieren, Mikrofon einschalten, Dateien manipulieren, volles Programm.
Und diese Software hatten wir schon länger unter der Lupe, dass die illegal
eingesetzt wurde und auch dass
sie nicht nur an Staaten, sondern auch an private Firmen verkauft wurde.
Das war immer die Vermutung aufgrund von Werbematerialien von der CAF,
die damals Netzpolitik.org geleakt hatte.
Und diese Spionagesoftware hat dann aber sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit erlangt,
als Microsoft in einem Blogpost gesagt hat, Die haben das gerade in the wild
gefunden auf den Windows Rechnern von Banken, Anwälten und Beraterfirmen in
Großbritannien, Österreich und Panama.
Wir haben diesen Microsoft Post gesehen und sofort gedacht, oh what the fuck,
sofort Anzeige erstattet bei der Staatsanwaltschaft.
Und dem Vernehmen nach gab es da sogar schon Ermittlungsschritte, die ...
Jetzt aber dazu geführt haben, dass man das komplette Unternehmen,
was buchhalterisch mit einer Viertel Milliarde bewertet war,
eingestampft hat zum heutigen Zeitpunkt.
Auch die BNC Privatstiftung, eine sehr große, so geldverwaltende Stiftung in
Österreich, hat sich öffentlich zurückgezogen.
Und jetzt ist es zum Glück mal so
weit die Gefahr gebannt, auch für die potenziellen Opfer dieser Software.
Und die eigentliche Frage ist aber, was da jetzt strafrechtlich weiter passiert.
Ganz spannend ist, wie sollte es anders sein in Österreich, es gibt eine starke Russland-Connection.
Da verlinken wir auch noch mal ein paar sehr bemerkenswerte Medienberichte.
Da gab es auch wirklich Journalisten, die mit einer Inbrunst dem Unternehmen
auf die Pelle gerückt sind über viele Jahre.
Da ziehe ich meinen Hut davor und man sieht halt einfach von hinten bis vorne,
dass es da ein nahes Verhältnis zu Russland gab, auch zu russischen Oligarchen
gab und teilweise auch zur österreichischen Politik, muss man sagen.
Wir haben auch nochmal Informationen weitergeleitet an den Untersuchungsreport des PEGA-Ausschusses.
Also im Europaparlament gab es ja nach dem Pegasus-Skandal eine eigene Untersuchungskommission.
Da gibt es auch ein Kapitel zu Österreich, wo wir mitgeholfen haben.
Und ja, also die Welt ist sicherlich eine bessere, wenn es weniger Überwachungsfirmen
gibt und Hersteller von Staatstrojanern.
Insofern ist das heute eine gute Nachricht und jetzt hoffen wir,
dass diejenigen, die diese Software illegal zum Einsatz gebracht haben,
vielleicht auch noch strafrechtlich zur Verantwortung gezogen werden.
Und damit meine ich vor allem auch die Hinterleute, die das Ganze beauftragt haben.
Ja, schön. Also es lohnt sich nicht so richtig, so ein Unternehmen zu machen.
Zumindest nicht in unseren Rechtsgebieten.
Das ist die Hoffnung, oder? Dass es so einen Lerneffekt gibt.
Also dass man dann sagt, okay, gut, nee, machen wir nicht.
Also ich meine, noch besser wäre es, wenn die Staaten gar nicht erst so eine
Software einkaufen würden.
Weil, wieso braucht man staatliches Hacking? Mir fällt kein Grund ein.
Und ja, ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Schritt. Eine andere gute Nachricht kommt
aus der Chat-Kontrolle.
Und ich vermelde jetzt einfach nur und lasse den restlichen Theater Donner für
Khaleesi, die sich da viel besser auskennt als ich. Aber es gab jetzt gerade
wieder mal ein Gutachten über die Verfassungswidrigkeit der Chat-Kontrolle.
Und diesmal aus einem ganz interessanten Eck, nämlich von dem Wissenschaftlichen
Dienst des Rats der Europäischen Union, also von den Mitgliedstaaten.
Oh ja.
Das sind jetzt eigentlich diejenigen, die immer nur Verschärfung schreien und
dass sogar dort jetzt schon irgendwie die neutrale Aufarbeitung sagt,
nee, vom Höchstgericht hält das sicherlich nicht, sollte doch irgendwie einigen
Staaten zu denken geben, würde ich hoffen.
Aber leider ist genau das Gegenteil der Fall, weil ja,
es gab da jetzt gerade auch wieder die Meldung, dass es eine Gruppe gibt von
Staaten, denen der Vorschlag der Kommission nicht weit genug geht und die noch
weitere Verschärfungen bezüglich Detection-Orders fordern.
Insofern, das Thema bleibt auf jeden Fall ein großes, das jede Aufmerksamkeit verdient hat.
Ganz spannend ist aber eben auch so diese Perspektive, dass jetzt im im Parlament
und im Rat eigentlich schon von den Beauftragten gutachten, man weiß,
dass das vom Höchstgericht nicht halten wird.
Also wem Kinderschutz wirklich ein Anliegen ist, da muss man doch irgendwie
schnallen, dass ein Gesetz zu beschließen, das eine Halbwertszeit von Monaten
bis wenigen Jahren hat, nicht wirklich irgendjemandem einem Kind helfen wird.
Solche und andere Argumente machen NGOs in und um EDRI da gerade und ich hoffe,
dass gehört werden und ansonsten müssen wir halt wieder zum zum eugh gehen aber
das dauert dann halt wieder ein zwei jahre wird dann wahrscheinlich in so einer
ähnlichen lauerschleife landen wie.
Die vorratsdatenspeicherung oh ja unser letztes thema genau ibiza ibiza alle
Ibiza, Ibiza, Anzifaschista.
Also, wir haben ja in der Vergangenheit schon mehrmals darüber berichtet,
dass der Regisseur des Ibiza-Videos, Julian Hessenthaler, vor Gericht stand
wegen Drogendelikten, dort auch verurteilt wurde.
Inzwischen ist diese Verurteilung auch rechtskräftig, er saß auch über zwei Jahre in Haft,
ist aber im April auf freien Fuss gekommen, inzwischen auch ohne Fussfessel
und er nutzt seine neu gewonnene Freiheit indem er ihr Leben,
sich auf Bühnen setzt und mal über die ganze Sache spricht, wie das wirklich passiert ist.
Beim Volkstheater gab es da schon zwei Termine, wo er einmal mit Jean-Peters
vom PEN-Kollektiv und Korrektiv und einmal mit dem Antikorruptionsvolksbegehren
und der NGO Sauberen Hände über Antikorruption geredet hat.
Und es gibt dann zum Jahrestag der Veröffentlichung des Ibiza-Videos am 17.
Mai habe ich die Gelegenheit, dass ich auf einem Panel mit ihm sitze,
über Whistleblower-Schutz, über das, was man in Österreich eigentlich tun müsste,
um Menschen zu helfen, die Missstände ans Tageslicht bringen wollen.
Weil eigentlich geht es ja hier um den Umgang mit Aufdeckern,
mit den Leuten, die Korruption abstellen wollen. Die haben unsere Solidarität verdient.
Und das ist eine gute Gelegenheit, da mal über dieses wichtige Thema Wisselbohrerschutz zu sprechen.
Und auch, was in Österreich alles schief läuft, weil das, was damals passiert
ist, was ja der Auslöser von Ibiza war, der Mandatskauf, ist bis heute noch
nicht strafbar in Österreich. Also ich kann immer noch irgendwie einen Listenplatz
verkaufen um 10 Millionen, wie es damals der Fall war.
Und das ist komplett legal.
Darüber wollen wir reden und auch, wie es in Österreich weitergeht.
Es ist so, dass wir ja nächstes Jahr Wahlen haben werden und nach allen Umfragen
ist die FPÖ die stimmenstärkste Partei.
Und in zwei Bundesländern gab es vor kurzem auch wiederum Wahlen,
wo die ÖVP wieder in Koalition mit der FPÖ gegangen ist.
Also die Konservativen mit den Rechtsextremen, in Deutschland wäre es,
wenn die Union mit der AfD koalieren würde. würde, nur dass in dem derzeitigen
Wahlergebnis, wie es prognostiziert wird, die AfD den Kanzler stellen würde.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt einige Jahre nach Ibiza, vielleicht gar nicht mal
so weit weg davon, dass sich die Geschichte wiederholt.
Und deswegen ist es vielleicht auch ein ganz guter Zeitpunkt,
diesen Tag zu nutzen, um mal öffentlichkeitswirksam
auf ein paar Dinge hinzuweisen und dagegen zu halten.
Und wir verlinken irgendwie das Volkstheater. Wer es nicht nach Wien schafft,
der kann sich auch das Jung und Naiv-Interview mit Julian Hessenthaler anschauen.
Das ist wirklich sehr aufschlussreich und unterhaltsam sogar.
Also wenn das heute nicht genügend Österreich-Content war, dann haben wir da noch mal mehr für euch.
Volkstheater in Wien, neben dem Museumsquartier, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Das scheint ja eine ganz pompöse Veranstaltungslocation zu sein für dieses Ding.
Wie viele passen da rein? Viele.
Das ist in der Roten Bar. Das ist ein unheimlich schöner Saal,
da kann man sonst auch irgendwie Cocktails trinken gehen.
Es ist nicht so die ganz große Bühne, sondern ich würde sagen,
weiß nicht, 80 oder 100 Leute vielleicht?
Ich bin schlecht im Schätzen. Es ist jetzt nicht die große Bühne,
aber es gibt einen Livestream und ich weiß nicht,
wo man den findet, das konnte man mir auch nicht sagen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Newsletter,
wo man informiert werden kann und wenn es eine Aufzeichnung gibt,
dann werden wir die sicherlich auch nochmal bei uns im Event verlinken,
aber ich gehe davon aus, dass man von Julian jetzt noch einige Zeit lang mehr was hören wird.
Ich habe ihn auch irgendwie getroffen, als er dann mal aus der Haft entlassen
wurde und er hat schon vor,
sich jetzt weiter zu so Antikorruptionsthemen zu äußern und halt einfach auch,
ja, endlich zu dem zu stehen, was da passiert ist, weil er lange Zeit hat das
ja nicht offen zugegeben.
Und jetzt tut er das, was glaube ich die richtige Entscheidung ist,
weil so kann man aus dem Fall lernen. Da ist sicherlich auch einiges schief gelaufen.
Aber am Ende des Tages glaube ich schon, dass der Mut solche Sachen aufzudecken
und das sich auch mit diesen mächtigen Leuten anzulegen, der hat es verdient
gelobt und gesehen zu werden.
Und eben vor allem da, wo diese Missstände heute immer noch legal sind,
da muss man sich wirklich fragen, wo gehört Österreich eigentlich hin und wieder?
Ja, habe ich das auch so meine Zweifel.
Vielleicht doch mal wieder mit dem König probieren.
Nein, nein komm das war nicht besser. Nein.
Naja, gibt es dann zumindest irgendwie, also mit einer ordentlichen Krönung
seid ihr dann zumindest im Fernsehen dann für mal für einen Tag.
Ja du mit dem Ibiza Video waren wir auch weltweit in den Fernsehen,
das ist an sich kein Wert.
Ja aber das hilft doch dem Tourismus nicht. Bitte nicht.
Ach, Österreich ist eine kleine Welt, in der die große ihre Probe hält.
Richtige Demokratie wäre mir genug.
Ja, wir sind ja schon mit richtiger Demokratie zufrieden. Wir haben ja keine
Ansprüche. Wir haben ja nichts.
Oh man, Thomas, ich glaube wir bringen es jetzt zu Ende. Schön war's.
Schön war's, ja.
Genau und spannend von euren vielfältigen aktivistischen Aktivitäten zu hören immer wieder.
Ich finde es ganz toll was ihr macht und ich hoffe, dass ihr auch weiterhin
da so unterstützt werde durch Spenden um all das zu finanzieren.
Weil es halt, weiß nicht, ich find's ja geil, wenn Leute das geil finden,
sich auf so einer Ebene einzusetzen, die einfach auch so viel Frustrationspotenzial hat.
Ja, aber das Lustige ist, Tim, das verstehst du falsch. Ich wäre frustrierter,
wenn ich das nicht machen könnte.
Weißt du, wie rastlos ich irgendwie war, bevor ich die Netzpolitik gefunden
habe? Also, ich habe hier endlich ein Betätigungsfeld gefunden,
wo es mir nicht langweilig wird.
Ich kann was sinnvolles machen, man ist halt inhärent workaholic und abschalten ist schwierig,
aber man hat immer irgendwie sinnvolle Dinge, die man tun kann und man muss
niemanden um Erlaubnis fragen, ob man irgendwas tun darf oder wo dagegen treten darf.
Es geht nur um die Frage so, was ist jetzt das richtige Vorgehen und wie können
wir einen Impact haben und die Kohle ist bisher immer reingekommen im Nachhinein,
also du fragst immer um Verzeihung, nicht um Erlaubnis und für mich persönlich
wäre es eh so, wenn ich morgen einen Lotto gewinnen würde, ich würde trotzdem
wieder zur Arbeit gehen, also ich komme da eh nicht aus. Keine Sorge.
Spielst du den Lotto?
Nein.
Na dann bleibst du uns ja noch eine Weile. So oder so.
Alright, gut. Dann sagen wir einfach vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und nächste Woche
dann wahrscheinlich wieder mit Linus und bis dahin sag ich Tschüss,
bis bald, macht's gut. Ciao, ciao.